jeder kennt die glamouröse welt der
casinos wie man sie in filmen wie james
bond casino royale sieht anzüge geld
frauen doch auch im internet findet die
schillernde welt des glücksspiels eine
plattform vor den augen von millionen in
diesem video werde ich ihnen die bittere
realität des spielsucht eintauchen und
mit sucht opfern sprechen die alles
verloren haben um am eigenen leib
verstehen zu können wie sich glücksspiel
anfühlt werde ich selbst 500 euro aufs
spiel setzen um herauszufinden wie
schnell man süchtig wird die online
casinos aussehen wie schnell ich meine
500 euro verliere oder ob ich gewinnen
mache fast egal
jetzt wird es ernst zum ersten mal
online casino ich habe echt keinen plan
was mich erwartet was man kann hier mit
paysafecard zahlen um 1 gärtnereien
paysafecard kann man sich als
zwölfjähriger einfach einer tankstelle
wurde
herzlichen glückwunsch thomas haben
erfolgreich ein konto eröffnet ein
zahlen okay jetzt wird s mal wieder
ernst ich hab da noch nie was davon
gehört in diesem ganzen zeug
ich fühle mich als wäre es wirklich ganz
normales computer spielt 50 cent einsatz
ich fange mal kleiner okay jetzt 58 cent
weg okay ist nichts passiert alles klar
ok jetzt passiert was
tintenfisch paul rest komplett alles am
rad youtube in hallo herr das noch auf
was ist das denn
das ist jetzt 50 euro bisher gab es wäre
noch mehr ärger bin ja was habe ich denn
ich hatte überhaupt nichts so passiert
hast ja gut ich habe jetzt wirklich 50
euro gewinn gemacht dass er nicht
geschäftlich probiert man wirklich
einfach die einzug eschen und mit dem
geld zu gehen kann ich das okay ich mir
das aus da ich den bonus bedingungen
zugestimmt habe um eine einzahlung von
100 euro auf ganze 200 euro zu
verdoppeln
gibt es da aber einen haken nein was ich
dachte ich kann mir jetzt etwas
auszahlen aber unglücklicherweise haben
sie die umsatz bedingungen noch nicht
erfüllt sie müssen noch 3500 euro
umsetzen
[Musik]
okay beim blackjack habe ich mich jetzt
richtig schnell von 350 auf 80 euro
runter gezogen sind einfach 270 euro
jetzt runter fehler sie haben einen
ungenügenden kontostand ich bin jetzt
komplett brook nach 50 minuten habe ich
komme jetzt alles versorgt das waren
jetzt 100 euro in weniger als einer
stunde einfach ausgeblasen für mich
persönlich ist es noch nicht ganz
nachvollziehbar wie man jetzt davon
süchtig werden kann
deswegen würde ich sagen die fans raus
und sprechen dafür mit andré einem
ehemals spielsüchtigen mitte 20 ist dann
der verlauf erst für den spielsüchtigen
quasi sich einen automaten anzusetzen
bis zum gewinn oder eben bis zum verlust
online könnten mutter bin gewinne weil
eigentlich sportwetten
das kann ich nachvollziehen wenn man
danach lässt sich auch extremsten
manchmal ziemlich viel was ich verloren
habe ich meine wohnung mein job meine
freunde gewinnt gibt es nicht mehr viel
weitergeholfen haben eigentlich gucken
wo man gebraucht das weist so eine zahl
wie viele ungefähr
na dann verzockt hast was ich bin ein
comeback will schulden verkauft man muss
man leider nirgendwo spricht ihm bald
besser gehen leider haben einige reeder
du kannst mich der forschung aus den
streams von hunger und ich gehe davon
aus wenn du in der youtube sphäre bist
dass du auch klaus sie kennst ich bin
ich schön dass gerade gespielt wird und
bei menschen und jährlich kommen die
politiker wie oft man sollte mich nun
viele leute sagen das glücksspiel
verboten werden sollte will ich nicht so
gerne für mich gehört verboten
ich stehe zwischen zwei welten auf der
einen seite bin ich gegen glücksspiel
und wünsche mir dass niemand diese hölle
durchgehen muss von der ich gerade
erfahren habe auf der anderen seite muss
ich mich um mich für das experiment in
die lage eines spielers hineinversetzen
zu können
bewusst dieser gefahr aussetzen ok
wieder an die arbeit ich werde auf jeden
fall auch noch online poker ausprobieren
davor werde ich aber mal das online
casino von dem guten
knossalla probieren der erscheint es da
von der zumindest mal milde begeistert
zu sein guthaben 140 euro und wir fangen
wieder klein an der zehn cent
jawohl alge 20 cent krank vielleicht
macht ja auch einfach irgendwas falsch
schauen jetzt mal video an
alles klar
wie kann er sich dafür zu begeistern der
gesamteinsatz von drei euro hat er drei
euro kommt let's go
das gibt mir einfach nichts für jeden
klick einfach auf fünf euro in den wind
geblasen da fühle ich mich genauso guten
dünger um die ecke wohnen können gibt's
ja auch spiele die nicht einfach immer
das gleiche im prinzip sind alter 30
euro gewinnen führende einsatz der jetzt
ist er richtig los was her 100 euro
einfach jetzt hat er ganz kurz minimal
spaß gemacht wird unglaublich schnell
zur routine ich habe zum weg das muss
auch leertaste machen kann
10.10.10 18 55 euro verloren innerhalb
von ein paar sekunden
also das ist ja heftig zu gewähren um
mein gott was jetzt haben wir doch so
viel wie am anfang aber bis dahin will
ich gern wie funktioniert eigentlich
diese automaten ist da wirklich nur
irgend eine studie der
wahrscheinlichkeit dahinter und das wird
dann einfach ausgelost und zwar so dass
natürlich immer das casino gewinnen oder
wird da wirklich irgendwas dem zufall
überlassen keine erneut warum gewinnt
die bank immer die punkerin wie man das
ist so ein spruch das ist allerdings
nicht ganz richtig gewinnen auch die
gäste erster man spielt desto
wahrscheinlicher ist es dass der
casinobetreiber geld verdient gibt es da
also zu genaue zahlen und vielleicht
auch richtlinien es gibt gesetzliche
vorgaben regionaler natur aber so
insgesamt kann man nicht sagen dass es
einen einheitlichen richtwert gebe
der spielsüchtige mit dem ich vorher
schon mal gesprochen habe er war der
meinung man sollte glücksspiel verdienen
sind sie da derselben meinung wie er
kniet spiele bietet reibt sich die
illegalität strecken
was man machen kann
da habe ich noch gar nicht gedacht
tatsächlich also mein experiment geht
weiter aber ich habe gar nicht so das
bedürfnis einmal weiterzumachen denken
sie jetzt dass wenn ich das noch über
einen längeren zeitraum machen würde
dass sich das ändern würde wäre ein
schönes leben hat der wird
wahrscheinlich der spielsucht nicht
verfallen allerdings wer ohnehin schon
probleme hat das sollte die kriegen
davon
im spiel lassen das ist doch eine klare
ansage was kann denn ein spielsüchtiger
machen wenn er aus der ganzen situation
heraus möchte
es gibt viele möglichkeiten hilfe
zufrieden das ist gar nicht schwer am
besten wendet man sich an runze einfach
www spielerschutz punkt eu oder man
googelt einfach beratungsstellen
zusammen solltet ihr selbst hilfe
brauchen findet ihr einen link in der
video beschreibung aber auch wenn ihr
das institut glücksspiel und
abhängigkeit mit einer spende im kampf
gegen die spielsucht unterstützen wollt
werdet ihr dort fündig so heute ein
bisschen gefühl heute werden wir zum
ersten mal einen gewinn auszahlen wenn
tatsächlich ein bisschen motiviert ich
habe gerade ein bisschen blog was mich
überrascht aber letzten mal kurze gewinn
tabelle an damit ich überhaupt weiß was
sozusagen überhaupt bedeuten also drei
von diesen büchern die sind schon mal
stark und dieser kerl da ist auch gut
zum ein staat einmal gleichen fetten mit
25 let's go
die filme seien sie diese hier wieder
gehen auch ein bisschen runter hat schon
die hälfte von meinem bruder im verband
heute let's go wir sind auf 30 euro
runter ich weiß nicht ob das mit der
auszahlung heute was wird zehn euro
durch mein gott was für eine abzocke
also das zieht sich das endlich grad
echt heftig und wenn diese spur kommt
einmal und zweimal seine sounds abgehen
das ist tatsächlich echt spannend
[Musik]
ich habe noch 22 cent zwei bücher man
nicht wollte doch nur drei bücher drei
bücher
es war mein letztes kind sehen
freispiele netz junge war es fast egal
was neu abgefasst sind gesetzt und habt
wie viel gekriegt war der 10
ich habe einfach die vier cent einsatz
fährt 260 fachperson 10 eingesetzt
oder 0 0
auch dieser tag geht ohne gewinnen mal
schauen wie sich entwickelt nicht dass
ich jetzt plötzlich je länger ich spiele
umso abhängiger wird auch wenn ich weiß
dass es mathematisch absolut unmöglich
ist am spielautomaten langfristig profit
zu machen habe ich das gefühl dass ich
langsam anfange spaß dabei zu haben und
das ist schon beängstigend trotzdem war
auch am tag vier nicht der große jackpot
dabei aber vielleicht ja heute okay der
letzten tage ist angebrochen ich weiß
jetzt was kommt verrücktes tun ich werde
jetzt die 100 euro einzahlen und die
alle auf eine karte setzen wenn ich pech
habe ist alles weg wenn ich wieder so
eine fährt 260 fachen haben wir am tag
greift laufe ich mit dem 26.000 euro
gewinn nach hause wobei hier wichtig bin
jetzt ganz nach oben 100 euro jetzt mit
einem mausklick raus
[Musik]
das hat weh getan
wir sind froh war dass und sich die 500
euro sind restlos weg ich habe von
montag bis freitag gezockt und auch wenn
ich mir immer noch nicht vorstellen kann
spielsüchtig zu werden habe ich von tag
zu tag mehr spaß daran gefunden und das
obwohl ich mehr als zufrieden mit meinem
leben bin und wie er es schon gesagt hat
wer ohnehin schon probleme hat das
solltet die finger vom glück belassen
auch wenn ich nicht gefährdet bin war
das wohl das erste und letzte mal dass
ich mit glücksspielen kontakt getreten
wenn es ist auf dauer zu 100 prozent ein
verlustgeschäft egal was man sich
einreden will
und sind wir mal ehrlich was
unterhaltung angeht hat der automat im
vergleich zu anderen spielen oder
computerspielen einfach nichts zu bieten
im video von nächster woche werde ich
versuchen eine ganze woche in der
virtuellen realität zu leben wenn ihr
das nicht verpassen möchte abonniert
gerne diesen kanal und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder ganz gut
[Musik]